welcome to this video Doug game the game
young from Estonia right yep so not be
fourth got a regular Queens gambit him
the slab or is six and he started with
Knight f6 first that this is more
hinting at e six but you never know okay
so 93 for the Queens gambit why choice
no for black c6 Bishop e7 Bishop b4 yeah
this line is gaining popularity the rug
goes in i'm just going to transpose into
an Enzo I don't really know the big main
lines of the records and that much and
in the names Oh at least have some
experience c5 is the most popular move
now yep castles and now maybe the trade
here and again the trade so it took a
while to for him to set up this line the
cap off variation I don't really know
the details of this line just trying to
play Nolan moves and be okay I hope that
this is this is working okay maybe Queen
doing here and then look T 1 yeah maybe
rook c8 is attacking this night now is
taking immediately of course yeah and
now Quincy 7 is probably the movie
now Quincy 71 unpin no is actually doing
this I can go here and then maybe place
you for next trying to use my bishop am
but 94 is it could move now right 94
trying to take here yeah now i cannot i
don't really want him to take my bishop
the night only form is also not a super
stable peace you know I can't take it
with Bishop c21 and things like that not
covering c3 I also suc try to play
quicken not spending a whole lot of time
if i play ok he's retreating voluntarily
so let's push him and see what he's
doing be sure before I snow in the mix
yeah preserving this Bishop I think
really wasn't was an interesting way to
play should i do that but Bishop he's
going to f5 anyway but okay rook g19 f5
rook to e1 yeah maybe I can get a 95 now
soonish ok now 95 is not really doing
that much but it's threatening Bishop f3
and 94 oh ok I see okay I admit that
I should probably have put it on c3 in
the first place but okay not a big deal
yeah this was to be expected but I don't
really see a big threat or anything this
move is intending nie Dage form oops did
I overlooked something Oh Luke jakes
yeah of course I did overlook something
just rock chick c4 I totally forgot
about this idea okay it's not not
necessarily clear that this is so bad
for me
yeah not nice i can just play rock c7
I want to ultimately get in d5 opening
up both bishops okay store d5 no not
this time ok let's try to pick up the
queenside Queen g5 Rose an interesting
interesting way to play check
rook c8 how is he defending against that
now look aged a checkmate huh look at it
mate okay so this was one of the very
few ways to not get checkmated directly
but it looks kind of shaky I don't see a
direct way to win it's just a check
I don't see a winner unfortunately
it doesn't look good right but I don't
see you in check Queen d2 was a very
problematic move I see no se nothing
real he has nothing good amazing that's
really a shame but I didn't see anything
anything right i'm just a pawn down now
the Bishop's are so somewhat somewhat
annoying but time was never never ever
good for me so I don't really want to
take but he cannot take default as
Bishop c1 is checkmate them
check check hmm check isn't this tricky
now cannot believe that he's going to
survive this is unbelievable
unbelievable how did you get out of this
this is nonsense yeah okay it's it's
okay I don't really believe it what that
was a complete wind right about TM I
just I just win here why I'm not about
winning g4 takes h5 he's just finding
all the moves that are not losing
instantly now King well this is losing
but of course I have to do something
else now Bishop c2 and I kind of sore
books before but I couldn't believe it I
can take here right yeah I mean I mean
sometimes sometimes I really don't know
what I'm doing him this is just very
easy winning I mean yeah was the death
horse that was a very difficult kind of
game around him I was thinking I should
be okay I've got the two bishops and a
good center but he's got pressure on the
center so maybe it's it's about about
equal that this was interesting now I
didn't really see that coming computer
actually says it's about equal giving me
some kind of compensation maybe yeah Jim
and here that this is really amazing oh
I could have just taken his
yeah that's a very very simple take take
care and wide wins it's really winning
not just good because i'm getting check
I'm getting pawns quickly I'm such
that's a stupid just so easy yeah yeah I
was actually thinking that this should
win somehow but it it wasn't apparent
okay I can win with age three I didn't
see this move h3y wouldst idea ideas f4
probably and still g4 even if it's not
threatening immediately okay the
computer gives us the only line Queen d2
check check check came to h5 check and
now g3 intending edge form hmm yeah
that's a very theoretical thing I
couldn't find anything better than that
which is definitely not great but still
some chances and he played in the way
that I was really winning if I this is
just just losing check to exactly what I
played so I Jack didn't do all all
nonsensical moves I just have to chat to
take your g four instead of this this
idiotic bishop see to move yeah I don't
really know and I even spent time on
that I was actually so irritated that
that that it was still somehow
continuing I don't know okay well thanks
for watching